I remember like a McDonald's little
burger like off the dollar menu and a
large Coke would be my meal for the day
that's all you need that's all I would
eat like my mental health just was so it
was crappy I think that went on for
about six months it was just like a
switch I was tired of spending literally
every hour in bed and then I was like
you know what like I have nothing better
to do might as well hit the gym how old
are we I was 20. I literally remember
like what I was wearing that day and I
remember the drive to the gym to sign up
for the gym membership and then I worked
out and then I went home and I was like
I had seen tick tocks like right after
you work out you have to eat something
like high protein I'm gonna eat like
half a piece of salmon and I was like
anything is better than like a
McDonald's burger at this point so it
was just like a mix of tick tock talking
to people that helped me kind of get to
where I am and within like maybe six
seven weeks of working out I think I
really had it dialed what advice would
you give to girls that are unhappy with
their body or guys that are unhappy with
their bodies regardless of who you are I
think you need to implement some type of
physical activity for an hour and a half
a day